hello our guest today for a conversation
about faith and globalization as
Professor John Kelsey distinguished
research professor in the Department of
Religious Studies at florida state
university where he also serves as the
associate dean for the Humanities john
welcome to yale were glad to have you
with us tell us a bit about yourself and
about your engagement in issues of the
relationship between Christianity and
Islam I came to graduate school in the
University of Virginia right on the
heels of the Islamic Revolution of 1917
and 79 I had been interested in studying
Christian ethics and political thought
and the program at Virginia was
encouraging us to take up a second
religious tradition I began work on
Islam and found it absolutely
fascinating studied Arabic and went to
Jordan for a time and since then have
been writing about issues in political
ethics especially related to war really
since I went to Florida State in 1987 as
far as encounters Christians and Muslims
one of the most recent and interesting I
have participated in I was invited to
give some lectures in Oman a couple of
years back under the auspices of the
Ministry of Religious Affairs and
talking with students at the Institute
of Sharia sciences there the equivalent
of Divinity School and at the continuing
education site for diplomats in training
very interesting exchanges I have to say
mm-hmm when you starting to bring a
wealth of experience to this
conversation we're recording this today
on the anniversary of September 11 2001
what are your thoughts about the
significance of that event and what have
we learned in the last seven years will
the significance of the event i was
watching as i'm sure many people have
been this morning the replay of some of
the tapes that planes flying into the
tower
person I was remembering the I suppose
quasi apocalyptic feeling many people
had all sorts of strange and violent
things were happening and it seemed like
there might be more to come I know I
remember there was a lot of worry that
there would be more attacks since that
time we've been trying to learn about
al-qaeda and related groups that view
this kind of violence as a political
tool I have to say we have a lot to
learn still about the political vision
that motivates these people and about
its relationship to islamic tradition my
own view is that this is a Muslim
religio-political movement that is
deeply though controversial II related
to islamic tradition you've commented a
good deal on the role of sharia
reasoning in various responses by
muslims to contemporary political issues
explained what you mean by Sharia
reasoning and how does it differ from
Jewish and Christian at ways of making
sense of the world well that's a
question that we could talk about for
the rest of our time here but in brief
Sharia is a term that stands for the
right way to live literally it means the
path if you like the path that leads to
paradise and what one wants to do from a
Muslim point of view one of the meanings
of the term submission that translation
of Islam is to walk in that path Sharia
reasoning is the framework or indicates
the framework by which one might
ascertain this path and walk in it
usually the term of art and scholarly
works is Islamic jurisprudence or
Islamic religious law that's not wrong
but in my view is not entirely right
either because the series of judgments
reached about the path include things
that a European and North America
wouldn't think of as law strictly
speaking Sharia reasoning gives you a
fuller kind of sense of what's at stake
it really has to do with the notion that
all ways of living are not equal there
really is a right way to live and the
reasoning part is tapping into the
sources the Quran the example of the
prophet judgments consensual judgments
precedence if you will set by recognized
religious scholars and then an attempt
to argue about the ways that those
precedents might be extended to current
circumstances in my view one of the most
interesting features of current Islam
has to do with a debate occasioned by
the claims and practices of al Qaeda and
related groups within the framework of
Sharia reasoning and there's an intense
discussion about those claims in that
framework some of those conversations as
I understand them have to do with what
we might consider in the West a theory
of a just war is that a fair assessment
and how would just war theory compare
with the way in which the Islamic
conversation takes place right I think
there are strong analogies between
between the Western Christian Just War
framework and the Muslim the aspect of
Sharia reasoning that is called the
judgments pertaining to armed struggle
could you explain what those oh yes the
judgments pertaining to armed struggle
these are precedents as I was just
mentioning the the set of sources for
Sharia reasoning these are precedents
consensual precedents set in terms of
opinions issued by recognized religious
scholars now those opinions are always
crafted in response to specific
questions but the general thrust of them
runs very close to the Western Just War
criteria that is to be just a war has to
be authorized by a competent public
authority has to be fought for an
approved cause and with righteous
intention and within the category of
righteous intention
there are among other things the norms
related to the conduct of war that is
that one never directly and
intentionally targets non-combatants and
there is a debate as well about certain
weapons and tactics that is parallel to
the Just War discussion of proportion of
means one of the issues that is of
greatest import in the contemporary
Muslim debate about al-qaeda and related
groups clearly has to do with the
targeting issue can a Muslim fight in a
way that does away with the distinctions
between combatants and non-combatants
and still claim to be involved in a just
war or an honorable war something that
deserves the term jihad as well there is
a debate about whether or not some have
bin Laden and Ayman al-zawahiri and
others actually have the competence to
appeal to Muslims to come and fight in a
particular cause so there are a number
of debate around al Qaeda's appeal to
this judgments pertaining to armed
struggle tradition interesting to see
those parallels like to ask a as
somewhat lime to a question are there
fundamentally different ways of relating
religious faith and the political and
social realms in Christianity and Islam
and if so how would you describe those
differences well one of the great
slogans in Islamic political thought
arising out of populist groups like the
Muslim brothers movement from the 1920s
one of the things that on the sheee
Muslims side the Ayatollah Khomeini
stood for is expressed in the slogan
that Islam knows no distinction between
religion and politics now historically
speaking that's not true Islamic states
have been organized in ways that
recognized spheres of authority some for
political rulers some for religious
rulers it is true that in Muslim
tradition in Sharia reasoning the great
precedent which is cited by contemporary
advic
it's of uniting religion and politics is
that a legitimate state has to have an
Islamic religious establishment and that
is a very strong precedent we have some
people a tradition going back a hundred
years or so who you might call Muslim
advocates of democracy these are very
interesting interpreters of Islamic
tradition some of the most prominent in
Europe and North America they're located
in Europe and North America today and
they argue that this notion of an
Islamic religious establishment is no
longer valid based on their reading of
Sharia sources their engagement in
Sharia reasoning nevertheless there's a
strong tradition here when the Ayatollah
Khomeini was asked one time in an
interview about the gospel tradition
cited by many Christians as a way of
justifying a separation between church
and state he was asked what did Jesus
mean when he said render to Caesar the
things that are Caesar's and to God the
things that are gods and home a nice EDD
I don't think Jesus said that or if he
did he didn't mean what you think he
means because true prophecy are
following the path of prophecy home
Annie said always means to knock down
those idols that would keep human beings
from becoming their true selves and one
of those idols is represented by what he
would have called tyrannical regimes or
more generally regimes that rule by
human law rather than by divine law so
there's a great debate now over exactly
what that means but I think you would
have to say that the drift of Islamic
political thought one of the strong
dimensions over the last hundred years
or so has been this notion that there
needs to be an Islamic religious
establishment and so while you might
distinguish some spheres of religious
and political authority you wouldn't
separate them say along the lines of the
First Amendment to the Constitution of
the United
dates it's interesting that you
mentioned some geographical differences
in Islam between let's say America and
Western Europe and the Middle East Islam
is obviously a very large and complex
religious and cultural tradition can you
cite some other examples in addition to
the one you just noted that where
Islamic traditions of being harnessed to
provide positive political and economic
development will positive political in
economic development may not always of
course be the kind of argument that's
made by Muslim advocates of democracy
we'd have to talk about that some
certainly the most eloquent advocates of
the consonants between Islam and the
International Human Rights regime do
seem right now to be located in Europe
and North America though there is a
great debate interestingly enough in
Iran over these matters once you get the
state committed to the notion that
governance by the Sharia is equivalent
to the rule of law the sources of Sharia
reasoning to allow for considerable
debate about things like the proper role
of women about economic conditions and
the structures of Taxation and so on a
lot of people would also cite a state
like Indonesia as a place where Islam is
interacting with other religious
traditions in a religiously pluralistic
environment and contributing to economic
development especially say a little bit
more about the issue of Islamic
tradition and democracy you mean along
the lines of how the argument is made
yes well if you think of Islamic
tradition as presenting a set of images
that resonate with believers and help
them to think about the kind of
political order they ought to struggle
for the militants appeal say to Muhammad
at Medina where he is fighting against
religious persecution
to establish a safe haven for Islam or
they think about what European and North
American scholars called the early
Islamic conquests the militants present
a vision of this as a a program of
liberation and regime change throwing
off to radical regimes putting in place
good ones so giving a gift of Islamic
government to humanity the Muslim
Democrats by contrast appeal to Muhammad
at Mecca between 610 and 620 to when he
characterized himself as having an order
to preach and to persuade and so even
when his followers appealed to him to
authorize them to use military force
against persecution he said no that's
not the way that I've been instructed
the Muslim Democrats want to appeal to
that image and to say that the fighting
in Medina is very specifically located
it's not a kind of universal symbol or
image for all time they also want to say
that the political regimes put in place
by as a result of the early Islamic
expansion we're not universally just and
we're not universally a benefit to
humankind so its a mix they want to say
that there really is a variety of
precedents in Islamic history for how
you structure the relation of religion
and politics and most of all the Muslim
Democrats appeal to a text in the Quran
there is no compulsion in religion in
chapter 2 verse 256 of the Quran and
they make of that almost a charter if
you will for political thinking in Islam
it becomes the platform on which
religious liberty is the first of human
rights and the rest of the states design
has to flow around that how would their
critics view that passage and what would
they make a very traditional
long-standing precedent in Islam wants
to say that that verse relates
specifically to the question of
conversion to Islam so one who converts
to Islam must do so freely not on
dress as a result of being persuaded by
the message but that doesn't refer they
want to say to some further aspects of
the democratic program for example a
long-standing Islamic tradition if you
convert to Islam but then for some
reason become convinced that it's no
longer for you you become an apostate
and you can be liable to criminal
prosecution and punishment or heresy
blasphemy these kinds of things are
cases in which a long-standing tradition
says it's right for the state to be
involved in delimiting those things as
well if one reads some the tracks of
Zawahri a noose ama bin Laden and
they're not saying anything particularly
new in this regard the argument is that
the imposition of Islamic government is
not covered by that phrase so what
happened in the early program of
liberation and regime change in the
views of the militants is a gift to
humanity and it doesn't run against that
verse you need to have an Islamic
religious establishment they'll say to
point people in the right direction even
if you're not directly trying to bring
about their conversion by compulsion
mm-hmm there have been recent attempts
to find common ground between Christians
and Muslims particularly in the common
word document that was issued by a group
of Muslim scholars what do you think of
such efforts and will they have any
effect in countering Islamic extremism
well the last part of the question of
course is something that is hard to know
at this point my own view is that the
momentum in Islamic populations
particularly among younger people and
particularly if we're thinking outside
of north america and certain circles in
europe the momentum is with the
militants i'm afraid there are lots of
reasons for that something having to do
with
political protest some having to do with
simply catching a vision that presents
to them strong ideal that you might work
for now whether or not the kind of
statements made in a common word really
can reach to such young Muslims and
motivate them to work in another
direction that remains to be seen that's
not to comment of course on the
rightness of the argument or whether or
not it's a good appropriation of Islamic
sources I happen to think it is but we
all know that religious sources are
enormously supple and that making an
argument to convince someone is not
always the same as having a good sound
argument personally I very attracted by
the kinds of arguments made by Muslim
advocates of democracy I think those are
good interpretations of Islamic
religious sources but that's a different
question that which kind of argument has
the momentum particularly among the
young it'll be interesting to watch one
it and this conversation is taking place
within the context of a larger effort
thinking about faith and globalization
right and the term globalization itself
has a term that evokes widely different
responses both here in America and in
Europe and throughout the world can you
tell us what Muslims or different
elements within the Islamic world think
about that term and about the phenomenon
of globalization I'm not entirely sure I
can that is in any kind of general sense
democratization as I understand it and
as I think a lot of people around the
world would perceive it including
Muslims involves programs to encourage
democratic political processes including
the writing of constitutions and
imposition of the rule of law or
instantiation of the rule of law it
often seems to go with the increase of
if not free market capitalism at least
some of the tools that free market
capitalism uses like stock exchange
and so on and privatisation of
previously state held industries the
latter particularly privatization of
industries I think it's fair to say has
caused some economic dislocation in not
only Islamic societies but in some other
societies where government has held on
to certain kinds of industries as a kind
of employer of last resort now in the
long run of course such privatization
may be good but temporarily there can be
dislocations it's hard to know exactly
how populations in historically Muslim
countries respond to this except that we
know that where economic duress is
strong say in some sectors in countries
like Pakistan and where economic
development seems to increase the
divisions between wealthy and
not-so-wealthy people we know that this
can lead to unrest we also know that the
kind of people associated with al-qaeda
and like-minded groups are saying in
effect if globalization means
democratization if it means free market
democracy these are things that are not
good for Humanity so they are presenting
an alternative view if you will of
globalization in which the focus is on
governance by divine law and within that
regulation of the economy usually
presented as a third way between
collective economic policies and
free-market ones these are the things
that are held to be good for Humanity so
we can have some dislocation and
economic unrest at least short-term in
some places that leads to political
unrest and we also have these people
presenting an alternate vision their
goal really is to establish a state that
is large and powerful enough to affect
the course of things like globalization
either to stop it or to turn it in
another direction
in your writing you've positioned
yourself between those who see a massive
class of civilizations between
Christianity and Islam and those who see
Christianity Islam and Judaism is all
part of the same Western cultural
tradition could you say just one last
word then about why you position
yourself where you do and because that's
what the evidence seems to me to show
religious traditions I think even though
believers present them as they present
themselves as advocates of the faith of
a faith once for all delivered to the
Saints and have this sense that their
beliefs relate to something that is true
in an ultimate an ontological sense of
course that may be true of one or more
of these things but if we look at these
things from the standpoint of what human
beings are doing religious traditions
are living things they develop in line
with the interests needs psychological
purposes of human beings so religion in
the world is actually practiced has
human hands all over it shall we say and
that means in one sense that these
traditions with their frameworks of
authoritative sources like Sharia
reasoning are made for disagreement the
fact that we have disagreement means
that often time the clash is not so much
between traditions but within them or at
least we have to talk rather strongly
about that aspect of it when we're
trying to see how these things match up
in some sort of macro sense want to put
on your prophetic cap for a moment and
tell us what you think is going to
happen in terms of Christian Muslim
relations in the next decade or two
there is going to be continued turmoil
particularly though not exclusively in
the historically Muslim countries one of
the things that is missed when we talk
only about adversarial relationships
between
the United States and European powers
and groups like al-qaeda is that
actually these groups are engaged in a
fight with in traditionally Islamic con
context and that they are doing more
damage more killings more people injured
and so on in those contexts than in
Europe or North America we're going to
see more violence I'm afraid as well
we're going to see continuing efforts by
people on both sides of these great
divides great cultural and religious
divides to try to forge links and to
build bridges so that they can struggle
in their own way against the movement of
violence and extremism I'm afraid we're
in for a rather long struggle that it's
difficult to see exactly when the end
will come John I want to thank you for
giving us some tools for understanding
that struggle and thank you for being
with us today thank you